researchers at the university of
california davis are developing a
potentially game-changing material it's
called jelly ice and once frozen it's
reusable it's flexible and eventually it
can be turned into compost so here's
jonathan vigliotti showing us how jelly
ice as it's called could transform the
way we store and ship our food
at uc davis's robert mondavi institute
of wine and food sciences
a team of researchers is reimagining the
ice cube this is what we call jelly
isaac jelly ice stays just as cold for
just as long as traditional ice with one
key difference it doesn't melt thanks to
a gelatin membrane that traps water in
its cube-like shape so now that you have
this in its mold
what do you do to make it set in its
forever shape we put it in the fridge
that's it yeah
once chilled the cube can be manipulated
into any form ph.d candidate gianzzo
says this ice will revolutionize how
food is kept cold while shipped so here
we have two pieces of salmon filet on
top of ice and
jelly ice here they've been out for
about an hour already so you can see
ice already melted and then all around
is the melt water so the fish is
basically sink in a pot of water right
now cross contamination and inadequate
climate control across the supply chain
are among the leading causes of food
waste
according to a peer-reviewed study by
the journal global environmental change
nearly half of all seafood in the u.s
spoils before reaching the market the
whole development of jelly ice cube
started with
our concerns over the compromised food
safety and food quality loss caused by
temperature abuses
in the food code chain associate
professor luxian wong came up with the
idea for jelly ice after a visit to her
fish market when she realized there
needed to be a better alternative to ice
cubes and even ice packs
what makes jelly ice better than that
plastic packed ice we don't use plastics
we use protein which is
compostable plastic ice packs are not
biodegradable
and they clog landfills
wong says jelly ice is 90 percent water
100 percent biodegradable and can be
reused more than a dozen times if you
don't want to use them you can compost
them and throw them in your garden once
you mix them with the potting soil they
actually support the growth of your
plant wong and her team hope to
eventually replace gelatin with easier
to source agricultural byproducts
like proteins discarded by america's
soybean industry the idea is considered
so revolutionary the usda awarded her
team a 485 thousand dollar grant for
their research they all come from
natural based product professor dr gong
sun says in addition to saving the
environment this sustainable ice can
also save water and energy
as a researcher our goal obviously would
develop something
meaningful
problem solving
we're very excited about this and i
definitely feel like there will be even
more applications down the road
as we uh move forward
for cbs morning's jonathan vigliotti
davis california oh look at that
basically
we like it when we see our name you know
what fascinates me about this guy is
that somebody looked at ice and said how
can we make it better yeah you know i
just look at ice and think nothing of it
but somebody else sees it very
differently all the great inventions the
invention of ice itself keeps my drink
cold every summer no so
this gets a bravo for me i was kind of
smirking at it before but now i see it's
for industrial food yeah
and there's a big problem with waste
there it's not for stirring your drink
flat but
but i think that if it proves to be
something that you can place in a drink
that would be great because part of the
problem with any drink is dilution when
the ice melts in a drink so sometimes
you want dilution if you're talking
about alcohol now true
but you don't want the flavor to go away
yeah i was like okay
i'm just listening to john tower going
gotta go we gotta go gotta go